[Music]
thank you very much what I want to talk
to you about tonight is how to have a
better sex life now there's good and bad
news the bad news is it's not simply
going to be a physical exercise I'm not
going to be able to recommend any creams
lotions or special positions I don't
believe that bad sex starts with a lack
of pointment I think unfortunately it
starts in your head and even though we
think that we think a lot about sex we
perhaps don't think about it enough or
not in the right ways I want to start by
asking what makes something sexy as it
were before we're looking at the
problems that sex gives us let's
consider what makes something sexy why
are certain moments situations positions
especially sexy I think it has to do
with loneliness for most of our lives we
are isolated alienated lonely creatures
who do not find an echo some of our
deepest needs in the people around us we
inhabit large anonymous cities and then
suddenly sometimes something miraculous
happens someone allows you deep into
their mouths you can put your tongue
right at the top of their upper molars
you can sniff around and it's wonderful
now it's revolting as well when we talk
about it nothing that is sexy is not
also with the wrong person
revolting that's the point
it's sexy precisely because it's private
because it's a miniature utopia that
you're creating with someone think of
oral sex in oral sex the dirty poisoned
a side of you is as it were welcomed by
another person you are no longer just
dirty the dirty becomes clean sex
symbolically cleanses us another person
accepts us the whole of us and that is a
miraculously exciting thing it's
exciting we call it a turn-on it's sexy
but it's deeper than that it's
psychologically enriching it makes us
feel fully human think of violence
within relationships within loving
relationship people will hit each other
scratch each other's backs call each
other names pull each other's hair
what's going on there trust weirdly it's
trust it takes a lot of trust within a
loving relationship to allow one person
to hit another violence sexual games all
of these things they're not signs of
depravity they're precisely signs of our
more aggressive impulses being accepted
within a social arena and there's a
tremendous sense of well-being that that
comes from that I want to ask why some
people turn us on what is a sexy person
now
evolutionary biologists have got an
answer to this question they tell us
that a sexy person is a healthy person
what we colloquially call sexy is
somebody who is symmetrical their face
is symmetrical evolutionary biologists
have studied diseases in the womb and in
the early years of life and have
concluded that people who have facial
deformities in later life are almost all
subject of some kind of attack
biological attack in early life so the
person we call beautiful is someone who
shows healthy lineage and we're deeply
attracted to that the biologists tell us
here's the work of a guy instant Andrews
who looked at pictures of lots and lots
of pretty women and then distorted some
of them and asked his students to rate
on a scale which
he thought they thought were attractive
or not so here a couple from sant
andrews now i think that most of you
should find this lady more attractive
she's a version of this one but this
one's got a nostril something's gone
slightly wrong with her nostril and
slightly wrong with that eye and that's
why we don't want to ask her out on a
date we want to ask this one out on a
date because she's dead symmetrical and
we are really turn on my symmetry
because we want to have a child with her
and that child will stand a better
chance of having a long and happy life
now the problem with an evolutionary
biological analysis of life is not that
it's wrong it's right sure it's right
Prabhas it's very boring it's very
boring ok so what if this is the case
that doesn't really explain the richness
of why certain people turn us on check
out this lady I think she's a bit of a
turn-on she was painted by arc in the
19th century school Madame divorcee she
is absolutely symmetrical beautiful face
researcher from sand and Rouge would
find her totally healthy from a
biological point of view but she's much
more interesting than that when she
turns us on it's not just that that's
turning us on it's the fact that we can
read psychological traits in her face
she shows a certain humor a tolerance a
dignity she's open-minded and yet strong
and when we say this woman is a turn-on
we turned on not just by signs of her
health but by a whole person we live in
a culture where we often very suspicious
of the body of the surface we hear that
phrase she only liked me for my body he
only likes me for the outside of me and
that's taken as an insult I want to
argue that a lot of us is present in the
physical envelope it isn't an insult to
say to someone you turn me on that can
be a deep analysis of who a person is
rather than just a shallow one now let's
think why are we not all turned on by
the same person it's because we all had
different backgrounds it's because if
you're a heterosexual male we had very
different mothers and according to WHO
our mothers were we might get a stronger
or weaker impulse to to take one of
these ladies out
on a date now let's imagine that your
mother was a kindly soul very reliable
very nice but a little bit dull indeed
on a bad day a bit oppressive a bit
rigid now who would we want to take out
of course we'd want to take out Scarlett
but she's a little wilder there wouldn't
be such a problem of rigidity with
Scarlett she's more on the chaotic end
as Philippa would say so we need a
little bit of that if we're inclining
towards the rigid however if you've had
a very chaotic mother she was dynamic
she was attracted but she was all over
the place your own real needs were not
taken care of well then Natalie might
come to seem a lot more attractive so in
other words when trying to analyze what
turns us on ask what's missing in us the
person who turns us on is going to
contain within them all sorts of
psychological traits which were
attracted to but slightly short of so
what I'm trying to say is don't dismiss
the notion of sexiness as merely a
superficial
category it's a very deep one there's a
wolf awful lot of human psychology in
the surface analysis now let's think of
the problems of sex one of the problems
of sex well they're really two big
problems of sex either we're having too
little sex who who here's having too
little sex
yeah I mean well amazingly well sexed
audience here and some of us are having
too much sex who's having too much sex
here who's in the grip of a sexual
obsession can't come to this later
well I'll talk in the buff now why do
some of us have too little sex part of
the problem is that the person we have
sex with generally is someone we're
trying to do an awful lot of other
things with you know in some cultures or
certain periods of history people split
out roles you know this person I'm just
going to do the accounts with this
person I'm gonna raise children with and
this person I'm gonna have great sex
with now we've rolled it all into one
this person is going to be this person
called my wife or husband and I'm gonna
do everything with them I'm gonna put
that the bin bags with them I'm gonna
raise the children with them I'm gonna
have sex with them I'm going to do the
accounts with them and I'm gonna plan
the interior decoration of our home
problem is that sex gets very squashed
among all these different priorities it
means that if there's problem in any of
those targets sex takes a hit so in
order to get back to having a bit more
sex what you need to try and do is
remember what it was like to see that
person when all you were trying to do
was have sex with them
now there's a website there's a website
that tries to encourage you to do that
don't go on it immediately later tonight
it's cool it's called post your partner
calm and on post your partner calm you
take a picture of your of your partner
naked and you stick them on and you get
aroused and masturbate to the sound to
them to the notion that other people are
watching your spouse or your your your
special friend and that's erotic now
what's going on there what's going on
there got to keep a straight face what's
going on there is that you're using the
libido of others to remind you of what
it was like to fancy your partner before
you started putting the bin bags out
with them you're using them as a guide
to remembering what's a turn on now for
those of you not into that
into post your partner com there is an
alternative this is the Park Hyatt in
Tokyo it's going to cost you about $400
a night
but it's perhaps more noble than that
post your partner but the same things
going on a hotel separates out the
functions and reminds you yet again of
who that person was before they became
so confused with other things
incidentally what we're being asked to
do is to reapply she ate something which
was always around and which we're not
looking at properly in other words the
problem of not having enough sex is not
knowing how to look properly we should
take a leaf from the eye eyes of
painters painters do this all the time
take Edouard Manet who painted some
asparagus in the nineteenth century and
the thing was we've all eaten asparagus
thousands of times and don't think about
it twice but MANET made one of the great
works of the 19th century by looking at
them properly looking at them carefully
and my suggestion to you is look at your
partner as MANET looked at asparagus
bring them to life with the same degree
of respect and complexity now let's
think about the other problem which is
having too much sex or rather being in
the grip of a sexual obsession the
problem with sex is that we often use it
not to think about stuff that's quite
painful sex comes along and fills a
vacuum you know when you don't want to
think and you've got something pressing
all sorts of difficult things to do and
you're in front of a computer what might
you do guys guys what might you do yeah
you know what you're going to do right
you know what you're good have you got
it you're going to put something in the
internet right and you might become grip
a fall prey to a sexual obsession
because you're using sex to divert you
from anxiety that anxiety is important
and you're running away from it to sex
don't now some people in history have
tried to tell us not to have too much
sex not to think about too much sex
they've been aware of the power of sex
and they've got us to try and do various
things not to think too much about sex
and when we think about these people we
think oh my goodness how repressed they
were dressing the head-to-toe in gear
you know getting too turned on by the
sight of an ankle this seems ridiculous
we think in the modern world that we are
liberated right and that we don't need
to worry too much about the physical and
about the erotic and about sex cuz it
doesn't really matter what you're
looking at you can be thinking about you
know microbiology or the fate of human
beings you're not going to be distracted
by certain visual images these things
are not going to put you off then
you're not gonna change your priorities
just cuz there's somebody sunbathing
semi-naked next to you grow up now my
fate my analysis is yes we will very
many of us very sensible people get very
very very affected by these sort of
things now I'm not necessarily
recommending this but I'm thinking let's
think about the power of sex sometimes
to draw us away from things that are
very important let's not let sex be used
as a distraction from very necessary
internal processes
let's sometimes admit that a certain
amount of censorship and repression is
not just for the Victorians it's not
just for the religious it's for all of
us if we're trying to have a good life
part of that good life will involve some
censorship some repression to conclude
we'd be awfully sensible if we didn't
have a sex drive we'd be very mature
very respectable people by now we could
take ourselves seriously very certainly
we could almost be growing smug about
the sort of people we are clever and
wise and Noble fortunately we have a sex
drive and that sex drive doesn't allow
us very long to think of ourselves as
sensible beings because we know what's
going on in our minds we know every day
as we ride the tube as we walk the
streets there's stuff in our minds that
of a video camera was put in there we
would just look absolutely absurd and
that absurdity is rather nice in a way
let's respect how ridiculous sex makes
us it gives us enormous amounts of pain
but it also gives us that vital
psychological philosophical lesson to
remind us not to take ourselves too
seriously thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]